tardigrades are microscopic animals so
adaptable they can be found in extreme
environments even antarctica and
volcanic vents deep in the ocean
tardigrades are like a extremely
charismatic organism to work with
they're cute they have little eye spots
and eight little legs many scientists
like dr thomas boothby have tested the
toughness of these so-called water bears
with creative experiments they've been
shot out of a gun frozen nearly to
absolute zero and exposed to the vacuum
of space for 10 days
so we know that they're very tough but
we don't really know how they're doing
that to find out how boothby sent water
bears up to the international space
station and also down into the ocean
with his aquanaut colleague dr hunter
hines scientists are looking at how we
can stress out tardigrades and what we
might learn from their adaptations let's
get a close-up look at two new
tardigrade experiments and what we hope
to learn from them
so here we have a freshwater tardigrade
and this one's about 200 microns in
length the thousand microns on a
millimeter tardigrades are really good
you know microbial predators that green
coloration is actually ingested algae
that's within it dr heinz is an avid
scuba diver
he goes on these really cool aquanaut
missions where he took tardigrades down
into the ocean and left them there for
extended periods of time at increased
pressure i think it'll be really really
cool to compare the data sets that we
get from the aquanaut mission to the
space flight mission and sort of see how
these animals are able to cope with
disparate extremes of environments
so dr boothby has a fabulous molecular
lab
set up he was able to send me these
tardigrades the exact same batch from
the uh the space experiments in the mail
basically overnighting them to me they
come in these small tubes they're kept
cool as they ship across the country and
then we're able to just pull them out
get them back to ambient temperature and
the total grades are fine with that to
conduct the pressure test dr heinz packs
up his water bears and gear in dry boxes
and triple bags them for the journey to
the jules underwater lodge which is only
accessible by scuba diving down into a
saltwater lagoon so basically we take it
down to just about 30 feet and the
habitat has a moon pool basically it has
an opening at the very bottom underneath
the habitat which is just kept open by
the pressure so we're breathing
compressed air down here at 30 feet so
it's actually like a 24 hour long scuba
dive you can feel the effects of
pressure you feel it a little bit in
your head you definitely feel it a
little bit in your lungs that's extra
about 14 pounds of pressure pushing down
on you as you take each breath now of
course it's affecting the tardigrades
it's affecting me it's affecting the bag
of chips as you can see these chip bags
didn't do so well as the air inside them
compresses down kind of the opposite of
what happens on an airplane when they
expand air is pumped in from the surface
and the habitat which dates back to the
early 1970s is equipped with sensors
that keeps tabs on the gas levels in
space once you're saturated you can stay
down there as long as you'd like once dr
hines settles in his 24-hour experiment
begins so the hypothesis was that
tardigrades would be affected by the
pressure and that would be reflected in
the molecular data i took down a
portable microscope which can go up to a
thousand times magnification all right
so the cool thing of being here in this
undersea habitat is we can actually
observe these tardigrades live at
pressure at one hour they're fine but
now after about 12 hours they're really
storing some signs of this parametric
pressure affecting them they're a lot
more sluggish they're kind of
compressing a little bit that's all due
to this added stress of the pressure so
it'd be really interesting to get them
back to dr brufey's lab and see exactly
what's happening to them at a genetic
level but to determine what exact genes
are responding to the high pressure
environment dr hines will somehow have
to provide dr booth be back at the lab
with a snapshot of the underlying
molecular profile of the water bears
every hour but how we put a chemical
preservative on them which basically
stabilizes a certain type of molecule
called rna cells take dna and transcribe
it into rna if we look at what rna is
being made we can get an idea of which
genes in our dna are active so once the
experiment was completed and we cleaned
all our gear up we were able to pack up
these different tubes very carefully and
we just sent them in the mail back to dr
boothby's lab from aquanauts we turn to
astronauts 254 miles above earth who
performed a similar experiment also
under the direction of dr boothby so in
space there's two main stressors that we
know of one is being in microgravity the
other is once you leave earth's
atmosphere you're exposed to a lot more
radiation the tardigrades are exposed to
the exact same conditions that
astronauts are we prepared our animals
in just these sort of small tubes and
from the kennedy space center they went
up on a spacex rocket to the space
station it was a really interesting
process getting to work with the
astronauts but at every step in the
process we could communicate with them
see what they were doing they could ask
us questions what you have here are some
photos of a french astronaut thomas
essentially he's got his hands in a
glove box to help contain any sort of
biological material that might escape
tomah did a really amazing job taking
care of our little water bears up there
for us similar to the deep sea
experiment the role of the astronauts
was to provide dr boothby with a
freeze-frame image of which specific dna
was active at one week and then at 61
days using the same chemical
preservative once we put this chemical
preservative on the animals they're no
longer alive that will kill them but it
will preserve their rna as it was at
that exact moment indefinitely the seven
day samples are sort of the founding
generation that came from earth the
61-day samples are tardigrades that were
born in space and have never been on
earth before are there differences in
genes from terrestrial tardigrades here
on earth versus in space if we can
understand how the tardigrades are
surviving in these conditions over
multiple generations maybe we can
develop technology that would allow
humans to have a more safe prolonged
presence in space if we want to go to
mars for example
or if we want to set up a permanent moon
base these are sort of stresses that
people are going to need to deal with
once this experiment concluded the
preserved tardigrades hitched a ride
back to earth on the latest spacex
rocket making a supply run to the iss
they're now in our freezer in our lab
and we're working to extract the the rna
we'll be taking a look at what rna is
present and what genes were activated
under these different stressful
conditions although the data from these
two experiments won't be ready for
analysis for several months dr boothby's
previous experiments on tardigrades have
yielded some potential real-world
applications some of the exciting things
that we found is that tardigrades they
have unique genes that only tardigrades
have the proteins that are made from
these tardigrade genes they're actually
very amorphous they kind of are
constantly changing their shape so
they're what we call intrinsically
disordered proteins some of these
mutable unbreakable tardigrade proteins
help keep the animals alive in a state
of suspended animation even when 99 of
the water in their bodies dries up
tardigrades aren't the only organism
that can do this look at plant seeds for
example that's basically the embryo of a
plant that can persist in a dry state
but what we found is that if we take
these proteins and put them into other
systems like bacteria or yeast we can
make those
organisms more desiccation tolerant
they're able to stabilize biological
material in a dry state we can try and
make let's say crop plants more tolerant
to drought the pfizer vaccine for covid
needs to be stored at negative 80
degrees imagine if you could mix it with
these tardigrade proteins stabilize it
in a dry state and not have to store it
under these really stringent conditions
the application we're working on right
now is the stabilization of human blood
in a dry state having dried powdered
blood that you can add liquid back to
and reconstitute it and use it as needed
would be a sort of huge boon to health
pursuits powdered blood that can be
shipped and stored without refrigeration
is that possible we're working on this
now we've seen some really promising
results with certain blood cell types
very excited to to see what comes out of
this in the future if this experiment
turns out to show some kind of novel
adaptations and perhaps some new avenues
to pursue for different uh different
kind of benefits to society i think
tardigrades will continue to be tested
in these extremes so the hardy
tardigrade the mighty moss piglet
continues to endure and teach us
valuable lessons about how they adapt to
whatever the earth and the cosmos throws
at them
you